I brought you a gift first of all you're
invited anytime you bring alcohol so
wait what is this Villalobos is my new
tequila with John Varvatos started about
two and a half years ago we started the
process of working with Stoli group to
develop our own tequila and actually try
I know it's like you know this show airs
at like 9:00 a.m. and I'm looking at you
Nashville but yeah I don't want to be
rude let's do it Nick let's do it
Congrats to my mama raised a polite
young lady I will drink your tequila
sorry enough rain I guess we're
rationing it that is good it's so smooth
I was a little nervous because what I do
like a lot I mean I don't drink
everybody know I do that's really smooth
yeah we're excited about it so we just
launched this one on the East Coast and
the rest of the country is kind of
starting now but then we have Reposado
and then yeah how is well it's coming
out I'm gonna do it okay so we're so
let's celebrate real quick you want
another one okay fine I will um let's
celebrate and drink to your first season
of The Voice you don't have to / - I'm
trying to be kind I just want to
celebrate the fact they're gonna be on
The Voice I'm gonna kick your tail oh
that's not true
but for that I'm not gonna clap without
I refuse to clap for that man it has
been a good little friendly competition
so far though it has we you know eat on
the blinds which has been really fun my
first ever assembled a good team I feel
confident about and we like a lot of the
same sound yes I didn't expect that I'm
John and I would go head to head but noe
I knew it I knew it and they the guys
were talking I was like he's gonna be
I'm gonna have to battle Nick freakin
Jonas like what I'm not gonna win there
I'm like a mom like so not cool compared
to you
like what no boy ask feel time but I
love Priyanka and you know this me too
so cool but I didn't realize I will be
really I didn't realize like how fast
like well okay what was your first date
like first of all well it's kind of a
long story
but all so basically we we were told by
a mutual friend that we should meet and
he said I'll connect you guys he never
did and I got impatient so I direct
messaged her on Twitter and she she
responded we talked on you know back and
forth about a year on text and then we
finally met in person and it wasn't it
wasn't really a date or just met in
person and went for a drink and then
about a year later we went on our first
official date to the Hollywood Bowl to
go see the beauty the Beast live and
just recently we played there to kind of
end the first leg of the tour and she
set two boxes away from where we sat on
her first date it was very cool that's
so cool so what I didn't know that was
y'all got y'all got married pretty quick
like people I heard people kept going at
whoa that's moving fast first of all
stay in your lane exactly my own
business so - oh um no I think what you
know when you know you know and we heard
that pretty much from everybody when we
told people we were engaged but we don't
you know it was it was kind of magical
you know just within eight nine weeks we
were you know talking about marriage and
within ten eleven weeks we were engaged
and we got married in December last
years or one years coming up on the
first congratulations
[Applause]
so I heard when I was doing the I was
reading the pre-interview this I had no
idea that yellow freaked me in 2005 well
because I feel like I just got really
cool no no one cared about us in 2005 we
were just coming up and basically to get
other gigs we listed the other acts that
we'd opened up for but that we really
just meant that we were on like the
outside stage in the parking lot while
you were playing for 40000 still helped
us get a lot of gigs after thank you we
are you 20% now you're on tour for reals
about happiness begins yeah so this has
been you know quite the crazy year for
the family you know just a year ago
right now we had just started recording
music to get together again and you know
looking a year later we're finishing up
the first leg of a crazy tour and and
also the album you know happiness begins
but it all started with a documentary
which we call chasing happiness which
was kind of just to tell our story of
her childhood you know her father was a
pastor and we had a pretty crazy journey
in the church and then into our music
career together and we had really no
intention of getting the band back
together
but after filming for a little while and
kind of healing some of those family
wounds that were there from our years of
working together in the past we were
able to look at this with a fresh view
and and really kind of all in different
ways find our happiness and so we we
went for it and it's been an
unforgettable year it's been really
amazing that's really cool like not only
I mean I get like the fans are excited
about it but it's way more cool for you
and your family like that's a hard thing
to like I mean that's my road family
over there and it's it's hard to all be
together all the time especially when
you're elated I can't even imagine that
that's really cool but this is really
special to share that with the
documentary would you release it if
y'all wouldn't have gotten together I
think so yeah I think you know we had
spent money making it so we probably I
think it was an important story to tell
you know that was kind of I think the
thing that was to us so special about it
is that there was no intention to come
back and do this again the beginning but
when we actually just sat down to the
hard work that you know most families
have to do we all go through things the
people we love and whether it's the
family you choose yeah you got to go
through it
and and and we did and you know we look
at the other side and we're all kind of
in the best place in our lives I know
you're all married now like yeah Bobby's
got two kids and it's a beautiful time
and to have been able to go through that
with your families is I think we're all
really grateful and aware of how unique
it is and so it's just been so cool I
will say you have like the most famous
family ever it's like looking at
everyone listed in your family tree I'm
like okay well it's dad those kids are
gonna be like they're not gonna know
what normal is like to have some cool
aunts
it's amazing y'all should have written
that you shouldn't but you should have a
reality show I just want to see it
I want to watch the dynamic of all those
famous people with one family that's
amazing man might break up again if we
if cameras are there all the time no you
won't you have to be on point do you
have a favorite song on the tour I have
a few that I love it's like picking a
favorite kid I could I guess I can't
pick my exit to my songwriting to that's
hard to pick one but we actually have
just come out with a Christmas song
which has been a dream of ours forever
me too it's my favorite weight yarn on a
Christmas album we we're back in the day
with Disney we did a few just songs here
and there but this is like our first and
a real swing at doing a Christmas song
with the same group of writers producers
that we we work with the rest of our
music oh my gosh I love Christmas music
as long as you come on and do it I will
sing with you when do you start playing
Christmas music my staff will tell you I
actually started like two months ago
because I was wrapping presents and
Montana we've originally and I was
wrapping Christmas presents so two
months of it's like September
yeah never too early but because I was
wrapping Christmas presents November
December really busy so I was having to
do everything beforehand and you did say
that you were wrapping Christmas I was
wrapping presents
oh yes that's impressive I do that I
start shopping three days before
that's my yeah my husband is why I do it
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my Channel please don't
make me keep going